[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
food
oh
oh
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right
all right all right i think we're live
peter okay hey buddy how you feeling i'm
feeling pretty good man um that in and
out last night was pretty perfect
yep
much needed
supreme
we're live right now we're live right
now oh wow okay at least i think so if
i'm not screwing everything up let me
turn it on we're live right now yeah
good morning everybody
hopefully everyone can hear us
um
hopefully everyone can see us
me and peter we're gonna be hanging out
today uh it's gonna be it's gonna be
awesome yeah it's gonna be making some
textures hungover edition it's gonna be
great yeah we had a
go going away party for a friend mutual
friend last night um they're moving away
from la so
you know it was it was a good night it
was a good night
good night
i i had a lot of wine which is like i
think a sugar based alcohol and
that's never good on the system
so
we're we're persevering we got the we
got the coffee we got the spicy water
got the normal water so i think i'm all
set i got a cucumber
bro wait you have an actual cucumber
right here yeah yeah
i can't see you but you gotta trust that
it's here you know okay i got a cucumber
water wait i'm confused do you have a
cucumber or a cucumber water the
cucumber from the salmon
oh my god yeah i can hear you crunching
yeah
it's real
great so
we're back
we're doing it big
um
peter and i are gonna take your
suggestions via the discord link it's in
the description
check it out
um
we're texturing your
suggestions we're going to speed texture
your suggestions
and
you know we've done this before with
modeling we're going to do
a few rounds here i'm going to do more
than a few rounds
we're going to start with five minute
rounds
and then we're gonna do a 15 minute
round and then we're gonna do a 30
minute round and we got sotomonte
um moderator supreme
behind the scenes here he helps set up
the stream he's taking your submissions
and he's putting them through
the sotomonte like pinwheel
thing and he's just
you know
he's calling the shots today so we don't
know what we're going to texture yet
but we know we're going to be texturing
stuff and
i'm in c4d peter's in blender
um
and then
i'll review your weekly challenge
submissions the top five winners and
after that after hours we're playing
smash bros
oh yeah
you you feeling okay buddy
i'm feeling okay enough to three stalk
you that's for sure
yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure for
sure just as long as you're in a good
place like mentally
i wouldn't want to you know put you in a
for sure dude that's very considerate
coming coming from you dude that's very
considerate
yeah yeah i
i'm trying to be better
so
[Laughter]
um before we hop in
while people get their suggestions in
uh discord link in the description
um
i wanna tell you guys about about my my
weekend i went to camp mograph and it
was the best time ever um
it looked so fun
was i telling you last night about it at
all or no i don't remember
okay
basically no it really was the best
thing ever so like
can't mograph if if anyone doesn't know
mograph.com people who run mograph.com
put together this camp experience for
people in the 3d industry
2d as well
and it's a place to go out and
disconnect from the phones and the
computers
and
really just
meet people
um share a good time together there was
you know hacky sack ping pong rock
climbing archery hikes i taught yoga
like it was so sick it was so sick
um
did you guys sleep in bunk beds yeah
yeah so i was glamping you know
we had bunk beds and stuff
but the whole time i was there i was
like man i was thinking of you and i was
like peter's got to come next year it's
the best
oh yeah dude oh yeah
um i would love to
yeah it's such a good time yeah you
could probably teach next year um cause
wow i taught a surface imperfections
class
ah
that's fun it was so cool it was there's
so many great takeaways like everyone at
that camp there's probably 150 people
there like people was there ashtorp was
there windbush ej
um like all the people who make
tutorials were there and that's amazing
yeah it was super sick um
jules from otoy was there
makes octane
it was great
it was really great and like
you know everyone everyone is very
understanding and just knows where
everyone else is at
so they're like ah you're going through
this right now man i'm going through the
same thing or i've been there
yeah a lot of shared experiences i
imagine definitely
yeah it was it was good
um so i'm still vibing off of that and
just excited to create and not
so
worried about everything you know
so worried about oh the stream's gonna
be perfect and
this is gonna be perfect and i was
watching mark robie's stream too
oh man yeah so good and like he just
doesn't care you know he's like
he just goes and he does his thing
and
you know his last stream had like a
camera collection he's like i know but
i'm not stressed out about it and i'm
like i could i could use a little bit of
that you know so
hey i mean the fact that you are so
stressed out just shows that you care
like for everybody watching clint puts
so much work
to these streams it
really cares a lot about
yeah and soto as well you know he's
helping out it's it's hard to do on of
course
on your own and i really appreciate you
um
being down for this so
what's up to show up last minute and and
do
textures with my boy yeah dude excited
heck yeah uh ciron i see you
uh happy to see you guys is what he says
thank you thank you sai
awesome awesome
so um
let's let's let's move forward
let's go over to
this two-person display
and see if there are no technical
difficulties
okay yeah yeah we're good so
this is what we're doing right we got
the prompt up top we've got a five
minute timer for the first
uh for the first prompt here this is
gonna be a nice warm up
for the both of us
we're going to create a texture
um
based off of your suggestions again the
link is at the top of the description
uh drop the name of the texture like if
you want us to do a wood texture
um show a picture of it upload a picture
and
simple descriptive text that says would
um
and
sodamonte will grab it he's working
behind the scenes
they'll populate the prompt
and uh and we'll just go for it and
we'll we'll have this first round we
have five minutes on this first round we
have to create it no mega scans okay
none of that
um we got bridge open ready to go no
dude disqualified i'll drive down there
and slap you myself
[Laughter]
like that 20 minute drive yeah seriously
um
so
yeah we're gonna try to do as
procedurally as possible i'm probably
gonna use my surface imperfections pack
if it's like if oh my
i'm a bit you know product placement
dude sometimes you just got to get it in
there
[Laughter]
okay where can i where can i get this
pack
well you don't have it you don't have
service imperfections on your computer
i got you know polygon surface
imperfections you use those okay
cool
i'll send you this stuff later when
we're not on the stream
okay cool um
but uh
i might sneak some of those in there but
yeah i'm trying to keep it as procedural
as possible i say that now
but
you know
i'll figure it out soto do you have
the prompt ready do you have the first
five minute prompt
shoot up
all right sweet
yeah i [ __ ] everything up sorry
oh my god
oh my god oh we're going
right now hold on moss five minutes we
have moss
okay that i don't know let's start
uh
i moved everything around where did i go
objects materials okay
i guess a glossy material huh
let's get this
popped up over here
um
yeah let's apply the material to the
sphere that'd be nice
i'm also gonna save my scene
my desktop untitled one
bright green and glossy huh
you heard me boy
all right green and glassy
um a bit of roughness these days goes a
long way
uh
octane
has an has some noise i could probably
use that
in the bump channel
what's your approach on this peter
i'm just going yeah i'm going full
procedural noise
putting that in the bump uh displacement
i got like a noise texture feeding
through a color ramp to give it some
variation in color a little bit oh
that's a good idea
yeah i'm going to try and give it some
maybe like a velvety
texture yeah cycles has a velvet
shader
for moss maybe i'll put this on a plane
instead of a sphere
this is like
low poly
8-bit moss
yeah let's get a noise
open that diffuse
uh
with a
octane gradient we have two and a half
minutes by the way
and if y'all want to join us in this
mossy
journey and the rest of these textures
i'll be taking a look at everyone's
submissions you can submit it on the
discord same link follow the link in the
description and there's just another
another channel below that essentially
where you can
submit
all your goodness
um this looks like
more octaves more octaves
right input i'll give that some very
oh dude the fuzzies if this was a 15
minute it'd be there'd be fuzzies
are we allowed to i mean fuzzies
aren't the real thing
you
could potentially make it work
and i can throw some fuzzies on there
can i do displacement
a noise
should be able to this might just crash
everything
45 seconds
oh boy
wow i don't know what i'm doing
this is about as far as i got dude
this is some moss from a distance
those are some swampy
mossy
adding fuzzies
okay 20 seconds i dare you fine easy to
resize my window though
uh oh
i feel like i can tone this down like
five
dude that's some like thick moss
all right dude three two one time's up
all right
what you got
yeah yeah yeah pretty good pretty good
it's like grass it i mean that would
definitely be like one of the quick like
mega scans uploads you know
yeah
all right yeah it it functions you know
i i wouldn't put it under scrutiny but
it works for sure for sure
um i don't know if you can see mine oh
damn oh you got the roughness map going
on that looks good you know it's
actually bump because you do get
roughness from bump like
because it's breaking up the surface
right so
but it looks like hair almost like uh
yeah kind of like strong across the
surface underwater moss or something
yeah
yeah very simple um
it's a very simple setup it's just
bump channel with noise here
um i threw a displacement texture or a
displacement node in there that's not
working so let me delete it
and then in the color channel i just
stole your idea and i have another noise
in there with a gradient that's going
between like a bright mossy green and a
dark dark green so there's a little bit
of variation in there that's it
five minutes so
what is
it what are we seeing on your viewport
it looks different than the texture
final
what are you talking about
i don't like the the noise it looks so
much different than what's being
oh i got you that's probably just
because octane and hold on my my stupid
screen hold on
wacom has this thing um yeah it doesn't
update sometimes like
entirely
so i don't know
good times um
walk us through your process what you
got going on ah yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah do you clean it up first off by the
way
okay so yeah we got our uh just
principal bd bs
df bdsm
um
which is just blender's you know default
shader it has all of the
physically accurate settings here
that's feeding through
a mix shader that also has some velvet
going on here so i can
velvetiness but a little bit i feel like
you know
you just have like the tiniest little
bit of velvetyness sauce
also have a noise texture feeding
through a color ramp which
is some variation in color i could
yeah
that is um
then that is also feeding into the
displacement node which is
that's it
sick very simple very very simple very
similar approaches i like the velvet
on it i think it's really nice
um
heck yeah let's see
what everyone else did
um
if anyone did anything if anyone joined
us let's see um
let me switch over to the discord view
hopefully this works
i think i have to open up discord
okay that's not what we want to look at
hold on
um
bear with me
bear with me y'all which uh chat is it
in
submissions it's at the top it's at the
very top on submissions dude
these are nice
these are nice
mitch mitch up in here as you master
yeah everyone's working with the noise
and the bumps
bumpy noise ted open noise i like that
lovely taco
very nice
that's good stuff good stuff all around
oh yeah ooh
ego robbie
that's like 8-bit style i like that a
lot very nice
michael
looks that looks fantastic
sweet
yeah we got some good ones we got some
good good uh good mosses
everyone's in we got mr ant popping off
mr ant is like killing it by the way
he is from india i believe and
is just constantly
sending me his work you know
and he's he's improving like constantly
improving he's so good
really really cool to see
um sweet yeah let's let's hop into the
next one here this is already fun let's
save our stuff here
um
let me let me let me properly say this
a live stream
let's see
speed texturing
and
somebody's saying flaming hot cheetos
lemonade cheetos oh that'd be pretty
sweet that'd be pretty sweet
um
you see how this is moss
five mins
all right we got another five minute
texture or five minute shader ahead of
us
so
let's see
just name it i'll name it in here look
at our moss five minute moss
boom
good to go
all right i'm chilling how you doing
i gotta go dude you gotta go
yeah you can wrap this up without me
yeah dude i got it i got it all right
everybody peace
shout out we got shout outs to give um
jan
petrasen
vibes um thank you for the super chat
i appreciate it i'm glad that you're
enjoying it
um you know we're doing this stream
without music put on your own music put
on your own vibes
uh leave the option up to you we got
i'll win thank you thank you
ren says make a uranium shader i don't
even know what that looks like dude and
ren is in here by the way
what's up surrender popping off hey ren
we're playing smash later at the end of
the stream you want to hop in get in
there
we got a proper setup this time by the
way so
uranium looks like
some kind of
but i wonder if he means like the
glowing green
[Music]
style
rhenium uh
oh something that looks nuclear slash
toxic
oh like a like um
yeah i got you i got you that'd be cool
uh adam bubbling adam robiel
shout outs to adam uh with the super
chat
victory big victory thank you so much
for the support that's awesome man very
generous of you
and alwyn
zero chance of failure
that's what's up no matter what the fact
that we're here and we're working on our
texture game means
that there is zero chance of failure
even if we fail
we're still popping off you know so
um let's get going let's do
the second one let me reset the timer
okay we got another five minute one
going soto um
i assume we got one pulled yeah
oh my goodness
give me a minute here um give me a
minute to just like google a reference
photo of this real quick
i'm just gonna go
generic uranium
radioactive
um peter let me know once you have like
a good reference and then we can we can
hop into it
oh wow okay so it's like
if yeah if you type in uranium
radioactive it's the first image that's
the one that soto pulled
okay
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay
i might go more uh
like a bubbling uranium lava for this
okay all right yeah ready to go yep
let's do it all right five minutes let's
do it
all right uranium
renderer so i can get some flow going on
for like
so that's a diffuse texture in octane
um
and it's dark up in here it's dark but
maybe it will save the glow for just a
second
okay
so it's like a bright green
i like the noise situation
in the color
channel
and you hit that with an octane gradient
and we go
right bright bright bright green
and maybe yellowish
touch yellow in there
get just a mix of both maybe it's a
little too yellow
run away texture with the color ramp to
kind of clamp some bubbles out of it
dude just clamp them bubs dude
i clamp them bubs son
uh
where are you bumpy
noise octane noise
always with octane noise projection xyz
to uvw
that way it wraps around anything you
throw at it
really nicely
i always crank my contrast to 100 so i
can actually see
what my noise is doing
let's see
uh three minutes
i feel like the the chance of something
crashing
would just destroy this
five minute run here
all right i gotta get the glowy stuff
going so that's gonna be
emission
black body emission
and we'll throw
rgb spectrum
which actually can just be this gradient
it's really bright right now
20 seconds
hmm
not too happy with mine it literally
just looked like there's no noise i need
to scale up the noise two seconds left
ah that's it
shoot
yeah oh boy is
right oh this is hard
i know
that's that's a tough one
hey yours at least looks like something
man mine is literally just green
emissive
like this i mean i think if you looked
at some radioactive uranium and oh my
god the discord is popping off
really wow
people
people have made some really cool stuff
specifically
lovely taco what the heck
it's amazing
well let's switch over dude you're
hyping it up
um hold on here we go discord
mmm good vibes only that's nice i like
the texture on that
wow psycho on that's really cool i like
the
fractal look on it yeah lovely taco
that's ridiculous
i wonder if that's a surface
imperfection or something that's really
nice you know what it could be
oh very cool
uh eating yang um you got that looking
good
like it's very subtle
barbvasi momo
incredible these are nice these are much
better than mine
yeah
oh that's cool that's cool
oh ren that's good
not ren wykman but r-e-n-n-e ren that's
good i like that a lot like it looks
like you're actually using
you're only emitting on certain parts of
it
which is great like
my whole thing is it's emitting on the
entire thing and my noise uh bump is a
little too small
so it just looks like one solid color
it's pretty bad actually
i would need some more time with it but
hey
everyone's doing great work here
that's solid peter walk me through
your setup
how did you do
your your situation here
so yeah we're starting with two
varroanoy textures which are just like
at the command
and basically just looks like this
nice mathematical
ears or whatever
and then i inverted that and threw that
through a
uh color ramp node
to you know give it the green limey
color and mix those two together fed
that into the
color channel and the emission channel
of a
support
the sdf
and then i also use that for
uh you know a little displacement and
what's cool about this one
is if i add a mapping
node to the textures i've used this
trick a lot before for like puddles in
the rain
and uh like a bubbling egg yolk
whatever you can actually since it's a
3d texture you can
move it in 3d space and you get like
bubbles
popping up and around oh that's super
cool
yeah
pretty well
yeah good little tip uh for blender
users if you have the node wrangler node
wrangler add-on enabled you can hit any
texture and press ctrl t
it'll bring up a mapping node and then
you can start screwing with it
node wrangler that sounds like a person
dude
oh me
yeah hey i'm a fan dude i'm a fan of
that it looks really good what you got
going on nothing look at this
this is the worst
it's like oh such detail if you zoom all
the way in you can see that it's just
green
um it's just green baby yeah so i i
let's go in here
so it's very similar to the moss
um
i think it's my the glow that's killing
me
really yeah i think it's much or too
little
um i don't know to be honest
see you can see the bump here but as
soon as i put the glow on
it uh
it just washes everything out so i think
i need to actually
localize the glow with like a noise
node or something um right yeah but yeah
it's the same deal you know it's just i
have two
uh
noise nodes here
added together
into the bump channel and
in the color
or the diffuse channel it's just another
noise with
a gradient choosing betw between two
colors again very very similar to the
moss it's like the same thing
um
but
i just this was i ran out of time
on this on this glow which
i should have i should have done the
glow man i should have got the glow to
work
my own fault that's my own fault
um
but hey for everyone joining us right
now peter and i are doing speed
texturing we are texturing your prompts
there's a link in the description
to a discord server
um drop us some suggestions we're gonna
do a 15 minute one right now we just did
something weird yeah we just did two
five minute rounds we're gonna hop into
a 15
um
take a little bit more time on this
and
i'm excited i'm i'm after this uh join
us right
we're gonna take a look at your
submissions
i got one more cucumber
in your cucumbers dude okay i'm gonna
hit the bathroom i'll be right back
get it dude i'll hold it down
mm-hmm
good to be back you know i went to
alaska
and did a crazy week in alaska a bear
safari and
uh we got so close to grizzly bears
and there's a part of me was like i
always wondered if i could go hunting
but after that there's no way
there's no way i could go hunting after
that those grizzly bears were just too
cute
and they were trying to get their fish
and it was just a good time
it was beautiful experience um
we went mountain biking we went kayaking
we went all around alaska alaska is huge
so much to see in alaska
i came back a week after that
and i went to portland for camp mograph
so it was a lot of traveling and a lot
of adventure so it was a very good month
and i'm back
after a week i feel like i'm finally
ready to get back to work
and i feel refreshed
i feel very good
i'm working on a piece of art in unreal
engine right now
something for a friend of mine a
musician
i'm putting together like a little six
to seven minute video
for
their song
and i'm doing it all in unreal engine
i'm gonna do a breakdown of my process
and that'll come out the beginning of
october october 2nd i think
so i'm very excited about that i'm
learning a lot i'm learning a whole lot
in unreal engine it's a super cool
program very excited to learn more about
it but
yeah
yeah things are good
no no no i'm not making a game um
maybe one day
maybe one day i'm playing games i love
playing games
but
uh you're making a game i know that
yeah yeah it's on hold right now it's a
vr game it's a uh action romance
game it's gonna be
pretty ridiculous it's gonna be fun
you were telling people about it at the
party last night and people yeah
actually down dude
yeah well we were talking to um
a guy who works at respawn entertainment
on like titanfall and stuff like that
yeah i gave him the pitch
he seemed jazzed about it which was a
nice feather in our cap so
yeah super cool but you're working on
your short film right now right oh yeah
yeah games on the back burner right now
i'm working on the short film you can
actually see some
set dressing over here
we got like uh
characters like doing a heist or
whatever so this is all with all the the
yarn and the thumbtacks and whatever
that's awesome how's it been going back
back and forth between
a short film and a game like do you feel
like it's a lot of work or do you like
having two projects to go back and forth
between i always love having two
projects because
you know i
i my work is also my hobby so i try not
to get too burnt out and a nice way to
do that is like if you have two projects
it's like work on one thing until it
gets boring and then you work on the
other thing until it gets boring and
then you work on the other thing until
it gets boring and you can just like
keep swapping back and forth and that
way nothing gets too boring and you can
forever
totally totally
i find that i'm similar like i have a
lot of hobbies and i love doing a bunch
of different things as long as i finish
what i started
it's okay to hop around you know like
it'll get bad if you can't finish it but
that's the hard part that's what i'm
trying to work through this month yeah
trying to finish that short film for
south by southwest
see what happens but uh yeah i'm feeling
good about it heck yeah man that's
awesome
that's awesome yeah brother
um we got some super chats to shout out
we got sadozen thank you for the super
chat thanks for the support uh vj vj
verma my goodness with that super chat
thank you so much
very generous of you greetings to all
speed texturing is awesome i have a
question for peter do you prefer to use
blender with octane
wow um you know i've never tried blender
with octane i'm sure it's great
i
only use like the blender internal
renderer or not the internal render the
cycles
is like blender's path tracing
under and occasionally i'll use ev which
is the real time renderer but uh you
know i'm happy with cycles i don't
really have a reason to switch over
i mean unless it was like
insanely fast or something like that i'm
happy with work
yeah maybe one day yeah and you seem to
love octane everybody who uses it loves
it i should give it a shot i mean it's
kind of like the first thing that the
first render i really fell in love with
ren for the longest time i was using
physical render in cinema 4d and he was
like dude stop and i was like no i have
to learn the first thing first and go to
the second thing second and i just
wasted my time i should have just been
in octane but yeah like each person has
their thing
[Laughter]
um
johnson
shout outs uh clint the left side your
headphone lines up exactly at the corner
of the wall
and instrument holder case meets
you are
being crates balance
i create balance that's what i'm saying
um interesting very very interesting
um uh what would you call that
um
my brain isn't working right now dude i
feel the same way you're good
derek i'm in like half capacity right
now
yeah yeah for sure but it's that loopy
kind of goodness
what you're saying
um derek parra
shout outs thank you sir thank you thank
you the burton charles thank you i see
you keep clamping them bubs
um
dude that's a shirt right there man
clamp them both and clamp those bubbles
i feel like that's a double entendre
what are you up to tonight dude orange
clamping bubbed you know
i hope to be clamping bubs tonight we'll
see what
happens got on the town
have some bubs
that's this that's the funniest oh my
goodness that's stupid
all right um
let's uh let's get into our first 15
minute one yeah great i'm so ready dude
yeah i'm ready to spend some time on
something um
let me reset the timer here for 15
minutes give me two shakes
15
all right
uh let's get that reset
we got 15 minutes
to
create
a texture that soda monte is going to
throw at us that he chose from the ideas
pool
that everyone is thrown in to the
discord server link in the description
um
sotomonte
i think it's time man
oh my god
wow
all right i'm gonna model a quick
croissant i guess yeah same
oh this is gonna be tough
[Music]
um
15 minutes
starting now
what's the quickest way to do a
croissant
i guess a cylinder
or just
cross section
oh that's a good idea
model from
doing a circle is a good idea
now i'm gonna just move forward with my
bad idea
let me at least at least throw this into
some symmetry
dude that's actually kind of jacked up
for all my blender users that saved my
life if you want to scale like
say you're scaling something like i'm
modeling this and i want this part to be
smaller than this part
but if i just scale it
now now
height of it also changes so if you want
to just scale on two axes you can do
that
i'm gonna press shift or i'm gonna press
s and then shift z
and now it's only scaling on the x and y
axes super can be
and you can do that in c4d as well by uh
toggling these little buttons up here
through the nc40 yeah
and i think i did it on accident this
looks like a janky banana
actually
ah damn it
that grid
um i like your modeling techniques man
you got some good modeling techniques i
like your modeling techniques i don't
know
i don't know
but hey i appreciate it man
the this is banana dude
this is the jankiest freaking croissant
okay screw it i'm gonna
pull through
what on earth
why this isn't a modeling challenge
and they're supposed to be like
layers of chunk
layers of chunk
oh so bad
dude i like forgot how to use cinema 4d
you want to pull up a quick tutorial or
something that's cool
yeah kind of in the same boat just gonna
have to make this work god that's that's
so bad
that's so bad
hey it's about the it's about the
texture
it's about the texture
that's what we're here for
not this like janky body pillow
oh that's horrible okay let's try and
texture this thing
um
specular texture
whatever
no
dude
pause i'm pausing i'm pausing i'm
pausing pause pause
i crashed i crashed oh
hold on let me reboot no no no no stop
working
stop thinking
there's a cookie
dude a cookie
disappeared oogie i think kim just
dropped off a cookie oh
thank you
i didn't even know
man
wow
unbelievable give me a second dude the
unprofessionalism
i mean honestly
that's bad
all right i'm gonna do this very quickly
give me a moment
don't you dare think about how you're
gonna do the next steps i've been
thinking about it this whole time
oh boy can i like uv unwrap this in a
creative way or are we just like just
materials procedural uv
i'm gonna wrap if you want
i mean
no
i'm not i see your c4d
yeah i know you're doing you got a moss
doughnut
i'm gonna i'm gonna re
i'm gonna remodel it and then i'm gonna
yes
i got my
i got my feet ready to jam out
[Music]
is that a shaker
[Music]
oh yeah
all right
don't you even move
don't you even
move i haven't touched my mouth
nerf dart
what do you call what you call
let's me about your water bottle oh
thank you i could see how you'd be
confused
thank you thank you
oh okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay
okay
people are saying i'm working on the
part of the screen that you can't see
just creating a masterpiece
okay i'm starting no no no no no god
damn it what are you even doing see i
can
look i'm i'm catching up
dude everything i see from you is like a
minute late because i'm just watching
the stream i can't see your video
[Laughter]
all right
let me just bevel this edge and then
we'll go dude
give me a second
making macaroni
making
beautiful
magic
save
so janky okay all right all right ready
oh yes all right three two one go
um
i'm gonna uv unwrap this sucker so it's
like
the curved surface is laid out full
oh what am i doing
all right croissant is like
yeah
okay
i need it to
wrap
around this thing
wrap this
let's try
cylindrical
all right so i know i need to get my
wrapping correct
but i'm gonna move forward
because if that is the last thing i do
then fine
but i'd rather have something than
nothing
nice golden brown
all right you got your wrapping right
how the
it needs to be the other way though like
it needs to go the other way
um right
crispy golden goodness okay you know
what
how much time do we have
seven minutes
oh that's a tough color to get
oh that does not look good
here's the questions like would you eat
this
that's the test it has to pass
um
can you not use a noise
or displacement
okay there we go
so bad
yeah i'm right there with you
hmm
i've never been able to get
this placement to work
this is difficult man this is very
difficult
not even on texturing yet
[Laughter]
dude this is laughable this is very bad
i can't even unwrap this [ __ ]
here we go
wow this is just a pile
um
it looks more like wood
than anything
here
so why don't we get easy ones man like
why don't why don't we have wood
all right um okay now
so bad
like this this could pass
for a croissant
that's not bad in a market
in a low poly video game
this is so booty we have three minutes
that was the fastest 15 minutes ever
jesus christ
all right time to start materials
dude
that golden crispy
goodness
straight up looks like an xbox
controller
oh no
minute
30. mm-hmm
yes
that's so bad
what is this
it's like a head crab
oh
oh
oh
painful
dude
you got the shape down
yeah you got the shape down 25 seconds
oh geez
yeah
yeah you got the shape down pretty
nicely
uh zero seconds time's up
oh boy dude oh oh boy
hey yours came out yours came out pretty
good yours actually is a croissant
um
mine is like some sort of massage
device
i don't know what that thing is but i
want to try it i want to take a bite
it's so bad i can't tell like would it
is is it would it be crunchy or would it
be slimy um
it'd be made of wood
and you'd break your teeth if you but if
you bit into it um
i can't model dude
modeling like i can't do organic
modeling for the life of me
um like i can model robot stuff no
problem but
organic modeling has always been my
downfall and
i've never really put the time in to
to get better at it just because i feel
like i don't really need to um because i
like doing other stuff
yeah
but hey here's me justifying like this
crappy thing um
we got a couple super chats um
melanie hey good to see you it's been a
very long time um welcome back thank you
for the moral support
and uh greetings to peter as well very
nice
mystic thank you for the super chat it
says clinton's a blast from the past but
your puncher app
still out oh my god that's so old own a
shirt you got an app son i did have an
app yeah
2014 or 2015 that's crazy
what was it for
it's some someone just reached out like
hey we'll make you an app it's gonna be
great you'll be our first customer and i
was like that's cool
all right why not you know um
yeah that's long gone it's long gone i
guess it's the discord server now
um peter walk me through how you made
a
croissant
so the important part here was getting
the uv mapping right so that way the
curves will follow
the shape of the
muscle
um
didn't quite get it right
basically it's it's unwrapped like
you're not familiar with uv unwrapping
it's basically like if you have a gift
wrapped present it's like
you have the gift wrap on the present
it's like what would that gift wrap look
like if you just laid it flat or like a
bare skin rug that's like
i'm doing a terrible job of explaining
this but basically
you know it's like an unwrapped the bear
skin rug is unlocked flat and then if
you were to just if a bear were to wear
a bare skin rug and you like stitched it
back up it would be
like pants and and a suit
so
basically it just tells the computer
where to put the texture and uh so you
can see this is these are all the
vertices of the model right here and if
i shift this around
that actually nothing is happening
because i that's why it oh my god i
forgot to you actually use
map
okay now it should work
no you can't change anything because
time the time is up by the way so it
looks good enough dude
okay anyways so yeah we got a uh a noise
texture that's just stretched to just
squashed a little bit so it looks more
like rings
and that's feeding through
another color ramp
uh node which just has you know the
round bits and
uncooked dough
a little bit of uh
darkness in there just for contrast and
that's feeding in
color input and it's also feeding into
the displacement input basically all the
materials have been doing is just like
noise of roanoi feeding into a color
ramp that's getting into the uh
color input and also
replacement and
a little squash and stretch little uh
turn down the roughness a bit give it a
line
got a question
that's very nice
yeah for me i'm failing on the shape
um
and and even the texture too it looks
more like wood than it does like a
bakery item you got the bakery item vibe
going it's really good it's really good
i'm learning i'm learning from this um
yours looks like um in the
i mean this is a compliment
in the like
1800s when you know
like uh industrialized toys weren't a
thing yet and so your parent your dad
would like
whittle you
a toy and it's like here's a i made you
a croissant son
there you go
it looks like the shoe insert you put
into the shoes at the mall
like but for someone with like club feet
or something like
dude it's so bad
it's in the alien mall where they have
like that that's the shape of their feet
um
it's okay i don't have to be good at
everything this is fine i like it this
is good good uh ego
exercise for me um god you need it
i know dude
i know i can't stop talking about myself
uh let's let's talk about
everyone else's work here let's let's
see what everyone else has going on
right here this is good
oh good damn
dude
people are so good this right here come
on
that's great so it's the shape that
that we all need to get down
it's the shape that's a brick wall
that's not a croissant
this is great yeah
cartoon actually zzz has a really nice
this one looks like a like a
like some like puffy crunchy snack of
some sort
ah ted that's so good
yeah i got those layers down impressive
it's the shape man it's the shape and
then
then you hit it with the noise in the
right direction and you're off to the
races
um
dude these are some some of these are
some like demented croissants oh my god
look at uh
roy the koi
i'm going top to bot or um bottom to top
right now so
this one's just
unfair
that's insane
that's a poop dude that's a straight up
poop
what
which one are you looking at roy's yeah
right
it hurts dude
so good
for us
oh my god matt madness
hmm
that's
that's good
see the here's the thing is like do you
want to eat it
do you get hungry
when you look at it
yeah
these are great these are great good job
everybody everyone's everyone's killing
it honestly
everyone's killing it
man
what am i doing i i shouldn't be
i shouldn't be uh making croissant props
or at least doing them in 15 minutes
um
as a job you know
right well thankfully it's not your job
how do you even spell croissant hey my
like preview window looks not bad
actually
yeah you can't even see it
but you gotta trust that actually it
looks pretty it looks pretty legible
yeah
um i'm worried what's the next one gonna
be dude give me a give me give me
something i'm excited let's do it um
hold on now hold on
two
one
super chats we gotta get shout outs to
um
save polar bears i see you
what are both of your inspirations for
becoming a vfx artist and wanting to
make games
and videos
and short films
peter you go first
okay good question um
dfx i got into vfx because i was making
movies with my like family's home camera
when i was younger
and i loved action movies and i was like
i want some freaking muzzle flashes in
there
and so i uh you know i feel like that's
honestly how every vfx artist starts is
like making action scenes and you want
some lightsabers so you google like
software you get your ripped version of
after effects or whatever
just to like
but like means to an end to be able to
put effects in your own things
and then over time it you realize it's
really fun and you just get better at it
uh yeah i mean
i i love the effects it's not what i
want to do like
as a job um i'd rather be doing
directing and stuff like that but i do
love it
i i think we're at the same exact
position because
i got into it because my brother had a
picture camera with a video mode on it
and um so i started messing around with
that
and i discovered windows movie maker
came for free on my computer
and i started i started adding muzzle
flashes
to my action scenes because i had
airsoft guns as a kid
discovered andrew kramer and that just
went off
you know um
and then like i was i remember being in
high school like messing around with a
program called wings 3d and it's just
like a free thing to mess around with
and i loved modeling like modeling was
actually believe it or not believe it or
not it was the first thing that got me
into 3d was was modeling
because i love creating i love legos and
like building stuff um yeah
and then just control yeah yeah it's fun
like you can do whatever you want and
3d to me was the idea of like you can
create whatever you want
as long as you're technically proficient
and like you know how to get there
so you're only limited by like what you
can by your mind at the end of the day
so yeah that's why i love 3d and then i
want to make movies of course um direct
movies
because i love so many movies and i love
the way they make me feel and i love
creating so
it's like a mix of all that stuff um
i think we're on the same exact
path you know are you ready to announce
your uh
concept not yet not yet okay
but it's
it's the one i found the one i found the
one
it's great i'm excited for everybody
peter was there
when i was like i'm honored yeah
like what do you think about this man
and like
y'all just started laughing immediately
and i was like okay this is good my
friends like it i like it it's it's good
that's always a good sign
get people giggling yeah which is what i
want to do
why i'm not at corridor i should
probably give an answer to that i
haven't been trying to like avoid the
question i just haven't gotten around
saying it um
they actually fired me
because i smelled too bad
uh
they were like you're stinking up the
studio
walking by your desk is i have to hold
my nose every time it's like a minefield
in there
you got to stop eating what you're
eating or you got to start brushing your
teeth and nope i will do neither of
those things
and they're like okay well there's
nothing we could do and they let me go
well
i don't want to say anything because
you know i could see it in your eyes i
didn't need to
um no but for real
are you still there
i'm still here okay cool i thought it
cut out um no i mean we're still buddies
and we're still working together but uh
i think work on my own project but yeah
like a part-time thing there now
yeah you gotta gotta gotta do your own
thing take care yourself but also you
know do what you gotta do to make ends
meet and everything oh yeah i've tried
deodorant recently
made a big difference
um if you guys haven't heard of it
you should check it out it's great you
just like it's the slab thing you put on
your armpit it makes you smell good
dude i actually don't use deodorant
really
i never put it on got that musk
musk no i don't think that like i smell
really but that's what i've heard that
like the more you use deodorant the more
you need it
oh that's terrifying i don't know if
that's true that's terrifying
well you really don't want
antiperspirant because then you know
trying to attract a mate you know those
pheromones do a lot of the work for you
i see anti-purse spraying up
that armpit it's it's not doing you any
favors
that's why you go with deodorant it
makes you smell good but it doesn't
block the sweat
that's a that's a that's a good point
that's a good point
um gareeb i see uh thanks for the super
chat
uh do an animated jet slash rocket
engine exhaust oh boy oh that'd be cool
that'd be uh
that would be a
job for ambergen
which would be a fun stream just messing
around ambergen that would be fun
we should do this challenge but with
like different simulations smoke sims
fire sims
i just don't know the program
don't you have it i do yeah i do okay
good yo cave's rd is in here welcome
caves
dude man i gotta try that new have you
tried his new demo i haven't tried it
but i've seen all the stuff on instagram
yeah it's
absolutely incredible man like
so caves rd for people who don't know at
caves rd
is
the like my inspiration for photoreal
environmental unreal engine stuff um
it's just so good like the looks that he
gets out of it and i just want to like
pick your brain to matt i want to sit
down with you and just like
watch you work or something cause i
don't know if you do streams or what but
yeah caves rd
on
instagram and you could probably find
the rest of his stuff from there but
dude it's so good and so talented and
it's it's like the visuals and the vibes
like the vibes are off the charts yeah
you know excellent vibes like super
chill music it makes these like these
little uh exploration type games where
you can like photography simulators you
have a camera and you can take pictures
and stuff
and just like very chill vibes very
serene it's
it's the life i want to be honest
yeah yeah it's it's what i look for when
i travel like i love traveling like i
was talking about alaska and it was just
rainy there
and
i just had ambient music on the whole
time
and there was steam and fog and it was
so beautiful and that's like i love that
feeling it's so peaceful
dude texture an armpit
good idea why don't you just go texture
in armpit bro
um
shall we shall we get into our
last
30 minute
round uh
no
yeah yeah usually smash bros
i mean always but let's do it let's do
it yeah no let's definitely do our last
we'll do a last one we got 30 minutes to
do it
hopefully i can do it better than my
croissant here um
after that 30 minutes
we're gonna do more cool stuff
just not texturing
so
hang out with us
um
let me reset the timer real quick
and
we're gonna we're gonna do it we're
gonna do a big
those 15 minutes went by so fast
it's unbelievable
okay i got the 30 minute timer set up
switch back over
reset the timer
yeah
i mean that's a clint question
that'd be sweet yeah that'd be sweet
you can try and hook it up
sweet
okay
yeah let's do it um
let me delete and get rid of this
don't delete it
um okay let me just prep the scene real
quick
figure out what we're gonna do
heck
okay um i'm set you set peter
yeah all right
soto hit us
whoa
[Music]
we're gonna get reference before we
start the timer
all right let me pull up some reference
okay whoa
oh dude that second picture wow
the one with the tree
well the close-up
these two close-up ones that's beautiful
okay frozen bubble
okay
that's all in
the
bump
actually i think i'm gonna do something
custom in photoshop
oh wow
yeah okay um
do you have
an approach
on this peter do you have a plan
lord of i i'm just gonna start messing
around with some nodes and see what
happens
plan
mess around nodes okay i'm gonna try and
hop into photoshop and make a custom
texture
and use that
on
like my bump channel or something
okay
okay
all right so we both have two different
approaches
to this frozen frozen bubble
oh peter's just cheating okay let me
start the timer goodness wait what oh
we're starting with oh sorry
all right just for the record we're
already going cheating okay oh my god i
had no idea let me open photoshop
goodness dude wait can i start now yes
dude okay
[Laughter]
nothing's stopping you at this point
um
let
me
adjust
this a little bit
all right
so it's kind of like in a
hexagon shape
but there's like
rivets to it
oh yeah
that's the
brony with
f2
hmm
i'm gonna make a brush
basically just make like a quadrant
here a little pizza
pie and divide it by six
i think i'm doing this the long way
but hey
i enjoy it enjoy
this turns into
a triangle cut
actually
you do like a hexagon what's the best
way to do a hexagon
polygon tool
shape six sides yeah
there we go
and
i rarely use this polygon tool
yeah let's fill it
black
and i just want
basically
it's the wedge
so we'll take that and
that's what we want that's perfect
like
that we just have
our wedge
bam so that's what we'll use to select
our piece
this here
let's see
this
i want to use to reveal
this
yeah okay
i'll invert that
reveal piece there we go there we go
unlink it and then we can actually just
scale it up and stuff
there we go
sweet
boom
one of six created
duplicate this
take everything and merge
cool
smart object that way we can
i actually to duplicate this
ctrl j
right up in there
ctrl j ctrl e to merge ctrl t to scale
transform
boom and
then one more ctrl j ctrl t
yeah there we go
wait okay so this is our brush
i'm gonna double down on it
if you hold shift it'll actually like
draw a straight line
in photoshop so i'm just clicking on the
anchor or on the
angle points here
cool
this will be our brush
scale it up
edit define
brush preset
soap
bubble
frozen uh frozen bubble frozen bubble
yeah
how you doing peter you still with us
yeah
i haven't said anything um
and just trying to figure out this i'm
in shape oh damn you're really good
oh yeah no jokes here
wow wow
all right so let's set up a brush
so i want to be able to scatter this
around and stuff
my brush settings
here we go
okay
there's too many of them i think it's
gonna be
under
[Music]
shape dynamics
scattering
yeah it scatters a little bit
the count we can take down count jitter
tip shape spacing
let's space them out a little
bit and then i think you can do rotation
angle
180
or maybe what if we just try like 30
degrees
hmm
i want that i want the angle to rent be
randomized
shape dynamics roundness
bitter angled jitter there we go angle
jitter
100 much time do we have
17 minutes
17 minutes
that's so sure
sweet okay okay
um let's go one more let's go one more
on that
this is a really cool shape
wild
i don't even think i need to make it
seamless
i'm just i'm gonna do this in the
possible way
you're gonna draw it
um
i'm excited to see how this looks like
this might just be it this might be game
right here dude
yeah
maybe maybe
maybe for you
um
plug it into the bump
no not freelance
there we go
moment of truth okay
okay okay let's wrap it
and scale it
box
and
transform it down
so it's a little like
intense
really
yeah let's try it
again
so like you can't it's too bumpy you
can't tell
like what the shapes are
so i'm gonna do i'm just gonna take this
down to like point two
okay
it's got potential um
let's try the roughness channel
i've been working mainly
so cool
good
it's so interesting
the light really shines
through those things too
they're like they're very
very smooth
let me go back to photoshop
and try
cleaning
this up a little bit
just come at these with like
50 gray
or
random opacity
when i do that
nice yeah that's kind of what i'm doing
just through photoshop
and i'm not even worrying about
seamless
because it has kind of a natural
seamless thing or it has a natural uh
way it breaks up
and then let's see if we set this to
we set this to black
or maybe
oh that's interesting let's see what
this guy does for us
10 minutes
ah interesting okay
um
adjust the intensity on this
let's see
we can turn this into a normal map
filter 3d generate normal
oh that's cool peter
yeah all in blender
oh yeah nice
i love texture painting in blender
with a normal
oh crazy
uh invert that
i feel like it looks more like a soccer
ball we got six minutes
and
dude thanks dude
i'm wondering if like
just going with different colored
hexagons
is really all it needs
it's a little bit more subtle
um
hmm
oh
peter that looks really good
yeah yeah yeah it looks really good oh
yeah
i think mine's like too rough let's take
this down
are you just in roughness
pretty much yeah i have a little bit of
bumpiness going on
mostly roughness
oh there we go
a little bit of film layer
i like the way you're going with it
i can actually
probably get the reflection oh okay okay
we got two minutes
let's see if i can do this reflection
real quick it's going to be a gradient
we're going to try loading up
a preset
um
[Music]
like a spectral
pattern here
full colors rainbow
we'll get rid of the film
layer just to see if this is working
yeah peter yours looks nice dude
yeah i think the lighting is
yeah actually
getting that like
gradient light
let me get an overcast day popping
off grayscale gorilla plus
let's hit them up ultimate skies what do
they got for us maybe
overcast
15 seconds
i think that's uh yeah five seconds
all right
cool
oh yeah
that's great i'm happy with this finally
yeah yours looks awesome oh yours looks
yours looks great too and like it's
actually different i feel like we we
actually came out with some different
results
i love the geometrical thing you got
going on
thanks man yeah it's um
it was actually really fun to create a
custom brush
in photoshop you do you you were working
in photoshop i wasn't paying attention
yeah so i basically like went into
photoshop and
made my own brush
out of like this shape here which is six
little pizza pies
put together
um
[Music]
and
stamped a pattern
yeah and just kind of like kept messing
with the different values and stuff
until i got something
that looked
interesting and i just plugged it into
um
my roughness
value here my roughness channel and i
just kind of dropped the gradient
and
kind of washed out the values a little
bit crunched it a little bit to get the
look that i liked um
[Music]
and then
i threw that same one into a bump
channel i use the multiply and float
node to like really chill out the bump
so it's subtle and then i actually made
a um
a normal map in photoshop too so i made
a normal map
um
photoshop yeah yeah
amazing
yeah so i did a normal map here and
used that as like an extra little layer
but like i i could definitely go to town
on this and spend a few hours doing this
and
get it roped in to look perfect but
um other than that you know i just
uh in in the material itself
i
in the
reflection
channel i just made a gradient node and
i pulled a little preset
of the rainbow so you're getting like
that nice like rainbow reflection
and
that's how you get the different
you know these different colors
yeah when you kind of move it around and
stuff
um
what was your process how did you how
did you do your thing
looks super sweet dude thank you man
thank you
oh yeah mine was basically
at first i was just playing around with
a bunch of different like procedural
noise
things
like really i had no idea what i was
doing ended up with
this
okay i have like some
swirlies and then some little wheels
here
that's sick kind of random
yeah i what is it even like it's like
planetary
yeah and then we got a musgrave texture
that's all jacked up
so
full swirliness and then
after that i was like i have 17 minutes
so i made a similar to you i made a
custom brush
it's just this it's total garbage
and then uh looks great i just
like hand painted a bunch of those onto
the surface and so this is actually the
map for here
cool
then uh yeah put those two together into
roughness
so you're all roughness like for your
roughness baby there's a little a
smidgen of uh bump map going on
ours
that's awesome go forward
super sick brother let's see what
everyone did on discord
i got a piece of it go for it go for it
um
let's pull up
the
discord give me a second give me a
second
here we go
nice nice
oh this is good
ye good stuff
very nice
that's cool i like that
this shape is good i like the
the way this shape is kind of broken up
and everything rage squid
really nice
mr j not bad
hmm
zachter that's that's nice looks good
this is a tough one
definitely a tough one
but my favorite no doubt is my favorite
that's that's uh yeah they're coming in
slow mode they're
slipping in there looks good
very nice
super sick
um so when i was
at uh camp mograph
this last weekend i taught a surface
imperfection class
and we actually busted out like
a white and black poster board and we
had black paint to work with we had
steel wool scrub brushes spritz bottles
isopropyl alcohol
and flour
and water
and we just got our hands dirty and made
all these different textures i made some
scratches i made a lot of grunge
textures um all that stuff is going into
my
second surface imperfection pack i'm
still working on it now
oh what's up dude back
um you're talking about at mograph you
were doing the uh making custom textures
and stuff yeah yeah that's awesome and
like
this what we just did right here and
hopping in a photoshop and making a
little custom texture is exactly what we
did but just with our hands and with
like leaves people go out and dip like a
leaf in black paint and stamp the paper
and get a really cool texture yeah so
that's what it reminded me of
um
but yeah people have some people got
some cool stuff some good soap bubbles
um
that was really fun that was really fun
and very peaceful
um
[Music]
some shout outs here kale
thank you for the super chat thinking
about trying to make roman greek renders
into a story and have no idea where to
start do you have any advice for what
i'm trying to do
wow what are they trying to do they're
trying to
turn roman or greek renders
into a story
well i think that they got a lot of
mythology to go off of there right
yeah and um
you know
uh a photographer of mine
actually had a really good piece of
advice and he said he said a location is
not a story
so you don't go to spain
and make a photo book or a photo essay
of spain
and just say this is spain there's no
story there so a location is not a story
and in this case a style
of architecture is not a story
so get specific that'd be my piece of
advice kale is to get specific
what about that roman or greek style do
you love
um
find a story dig dig deep like look into
some like
cool stories cool mythology
um
yeah yeah
uh
dig deep try and find try and find the
element that like really piques your
interest there and then focus on that
get as specific as possible
um
so maybe it's like an achilles thing
focus on achilles okay well what's
achilles about
was he the one who was like dipped in
the river
with the ankle keely's heel yeah
he's like held by the heel and like
dipped in to be invincible and then uh
right because he was held at the heel
like
they didn't want their fingers to get in
the water so they just right right
like you could do some renders around
that you know i don't know
get specific with it yeah yeah i mean
you could do the classic thing of it's
it's the uh corridor formulas you take
something everybody knows
one twist on it
that's something fun
yeah what's on your eyebrow is there
something in your eyebrow
eyebrow or is that just the camera
it's the lighting weird it did this
weird lighting thing your eyebrows fine
what was happening it looked like there
was a black fuzzy clamp on your eyebrow
that's weird
anyway
moving on all right
um vj
very very big thanks for that super chat
is very generous of you
he says that we killed it both results
look excellent octane glass shader is
definitely the best started with
veronica texture and dropped it
uh after 15 minutes yeah man thank you
so much thanks for the support and um
it was really fun these are my favorite
streams to be honest they're really
chill
and that's great they're fun to do with
a friend uh oh yeah
great way to spend a saturday morning
it's also so great like i love the
community feeling of it seeing everybody
else's artwork
and
having my ass handed to me with all
these amazing renders
great to see yeah it's so sick it's
super sick
um
kale we got another one thank you thank
you so much
um you want to have a story that follows
two brothers they get separated into
rome and
and greek from children to them as
adults where they find or they fight and
realize it's the other from the opposite
side that's pretty cool whoa that's very
specific yeah
this has nothing to do with that but i
heard stories this could be hearsay or
urban legend but like of twins who
will like be separated at birth and then
they
meet each other later in life and they
have like their spouse is the same name
and they have the same job and the same
haircut and they're like oh my god their
favorite color is the same really crazy
stuff
no idea if that's true
there's probably gotta be some sort of
version of that that's pretty
insane
wow that's a cool story that is a cool
story kale um roll with it i'd say start
small
start bite-sized
um see if you can do it in like little
comic strips
you know so you don't spend 10 years on
a project
um
but yeah just have fun keep keep uh keep
at it and uh ammar thank you for the
super chat very generous of you ddd
thank you for the super chat
uh
wait what
peter went to the store dumped a body
there and called his mom sick weekend i
don't get it
look here
i can't read it what does it say
can't read well it's so tiny in obs
um it says go to store dump dead body
call mom
okay okay okay
that's good dude that's good it's my
errands for today it's funny i laughed
thanks
um
so hey
we're gonna play we're gonna play smash
brothers
but also
is caves rd
gonna try and see what's going on does
caves play smash
uh
oh it's 3am
okay guys you got you guys maybe maybe
at some point we'll do a caves thing um
it'll be great yeah
unreal
yeah and if ren is still in here
we're going to get smashed in a second
um i can call him
and
sweet
um we have
we have uh whatchamacallit we have the
weekly challenge real quick to
to talk about the five winners
and then there's like four runner-ups
and the new challenge announcement so
peter i guess i just follow along as
best you can i know you're probably
watching it from a lag
um
but uh
yeah let me let me just talk about the
weekly challenge so over the last two
weeks the challenge was to create a
spaceship from everyday items
since i didn't stream last week it was a
two-week challenge so
um some really cool stuff
and i'll show y'all
right now
who the five winners are for the weekly
challenge we had nearly 100 submissions
um we do this every single week there's
gonna be a challenge this week it's
ongoing and i'll fill you in on that
in just a second but
first and foremost
we have frizzler coming in and this is
in no apparent
order
this is just cool stuff
like freaking awesome here
you have the phone charger unplugging
from the wall turning into a spaceship
and there's people running away from the
spaceship at the end it's so good
it's dragging the phone
the hand tries to stop it and they're
like go run run run run i didn't catch
the people at first that's so good
i love it
i love it
i just realized too peter
i need to add you i need to add you to
this uh
this layout
real quick um
or you know what hey peter why don't
absolutely absolutely
hey peter do you want to
you want me to add you to this or do you
want to just take like five minutes and
chill
yeah get a room going get a room going
and i'll i'll join up um
i'll go i'll get through
the other winners so hey frizzler
congrats you're winning the challenge
winner roll um
for this week
that
basically gives you access to the full
discord server including the pro tier
channels where we're going to do game
night we do our first game night pretty
soon here um art review
um you can ask me anything all that good
stuff
so congratulations to you getting that
getting that uh challenge winner role
all right
next up
we have
bam folio with this one this one's so
cool
um there is music with it i'm gonna post
the winners on the discord server
after this
but i don't know if it's music i can use
on the stream but
super cool
it's like a work
a work wrench i don't know is this
called a monkey wrench i don't know if
this is called a monkey wrench but it's
a wrench
you can tell what it is i love it it
looks beautiful it's very well lit well
rendered um
nice blue atmosphere in the space there
super cool design
i really dig it polio congratulations
you got the challenge winner roll
for this
week that's awesome
so cool
yes
that's amazing
beautiful design
good colors
you can tell what it is too there's like
point definitely points for like knowing
what
what this is
let's go to the next one
this is by
apologies if i'm mispronouncing that but
this is sick
it's a big old shoe a spaceship shoe
and the angle of which
you know how it's shot from
is beautiful
looks like you're actually there looking
up at this thing taking a photo of it
it's very well
not composited but composed that's the
word i'm looking for
very well composed and it's well lit you
can tell what it is immediately
it's a really really cool render i dig
this one a lot da uh deybot did ya
congratulations you got the challenge
winner roll this week
super cool great render good color good
composition
i dig it
next up we got two more
for this week
creep of steel
with this beautiful animation
couldn't be better
so good so good so good
beautiful render quality beautiful
lighting beautiful textures
amazing absolutely amazing you can
actually tell like you're making the
spaceship from a
you know like a hot wheels car
a lego character
and it looks like some
uh
you know lighters
strapped to the side of this thing going
around the globe it's really nice it's
so nice
big congratulations to ya creep of steel
got the challenge winner roll this week
i love it i love it cinematic wide
screen beautiful colors
so well executed camera shake is perfect
this is just a perfect render
love it so so much
congrats
all right and finally
last but not least we have one dead duck
with this awesome
uh
power drill
spaceship it's two power drills smacked
together
as some sort of like space fighter craft
it looks so beautiful
really cool design really cool idea
great use of the prompt
you're just knocking it out of the park
your backgrounds are ridiculous
i'm assuming that's a photo
and you composited them in
but i'm not really sure regardless it
looks amazing
and
wonder duck always puts out solid work
and this is no exception so
congratulations one dead duck and to the
rest of the challenge winners this week
you got the challenge winner roll
opening up the full discord server pro
tier
good stuff very very good stuff
we got a couple uh honorable mentions i
want to talk about
so we'll start with nugget
this is an awesome one this is like uh
paul chad heason if y'all know paul
chadhasen
on instagram it's that's where i consume
his content uh which is probably the
worst place to consume his content
because
it's so tiny i mean really honestly
instagram is probably one of the worst
places to consume any piece of content
because it's all so tiny
but
i got sidetracked there for sure this is
awesome it's a mechanical pencil with
eraser spaceships on the side
really nice gribble really nice lighting
great composition
nugget congratulations this is really
really nice honorable mention here karam
yes it is me karam
i love this this is
such a beautiful render and it just has
a lot of nostalgia baked into it feels
very fun it's lit well it's rendered
very well it's shot well
and
it's built well
a spaceship from a water bottle some
straws looks like a milk carton some
cardboard and toothpicks
i love it
very very nice karam congrats honorable
mention i had to shout you out it was
too good too good not to get the shout
out
we got a addicted lung destroyer next
um
yeah it looks like a lighter it's
another lighter
kind of looking like a tie fighter star
wars
kind of spacecraft i love it it's
composited well the color color's really
nice it's rendered well
maybe a little heavy on the chromatic
aberration you got to watch out for that
in the corners there but it's really not
that big of a deal for this i like this
a lot
your design is very nice it's very
simple
which i'm a big fan of is simplistic
design
super cool
i'd love to see a little animation with
this
and a lot of people had animations this
week speaking of we got roblob with a
nice animation
this is super cool
i love your scale here you really really
uh nailed the scale this thing feels
massive and it's another paul chad he's
in style
render
and i say that just because paul chad
heason makes these massive
renders of
you know spacecraft he has a lot of
ships cargo ships spaceships that kind
of stuff and they just feel so huge
and you really nailed that here uh
roblob
so i gotta get you that honorable
mention for sure it's looking really
nice
the tiny ships go a long way that's
really what sells that scale and it's a
speaker
for anyone who didn't know it's a
speaker
so that's a
that's the weekly challenge for sure um
making a
spaceship
from an ordinary
ordinary items congrats to all of you
who got the weekly challenge winner roll
um
into the honorable mentions and this
week's
challenge we got a challenge this week
going and it was voted on by
the community
and it is going to be
i believe i don't want to say it wrong
yep all right it's weapon right so you
gotta hand model this one yourself hand
model a weapon
yourself
no downloads just get in there and make
it from scratch have a blast with it you
have one week uh you have to deliver by
friday this friday
by 9 a.m i believe
yeah 9 a.m pst that'll give me enough
time to go over everything and choose
the five winners so get your weapon
renders in model it from scratch
don't download anything don't follow a
tutorial and post it you know you can
follow the tutorial but just make it
your own make it your own
i think that's it yeah that's it
i'm very excited i'm being i'm gonna be
working on an unreal engine piece of art
here and i'm gonna do a whole breakdown
on it so
definitely watch out be watching out for
that it'll come out october 2nd full on
breakdown of this piece i'm working on
an unreal engine i'm learning it it's
crazy
i have so much to learn and i'm excited
to share what i learned with all of you
now
we are
officially
after hours it's after hours right now
and we're gonna play some smash bros
because i got a capture card hooked up
it's smash bros time peter's amped
uh i think israel did you get wren
yeah ren's in the ring
does he want to hop in the stream like
does he want to throw a mic on or
something that's a great
question let me text him because we can
get him in there
okay
great
okay ren's not gonna hop in the stream
but he'll play with us okay cool
what map should we do
random battlefield i don't hire you
hyrule yeah
all
right heck yeah
um
online
let's do this um
smashing
battle arenas
oh god we get to see ren's new main do
you know what he's meaning no
i'll just let you
it's gonna be something stupid dude
it's uh
you'll see
[Laughter]
all right let's full screen this
full screen baby
open the ring
it was freaking go son
okay
let me add ren to the call then
real quick
all right
let's well hold on now
y'all just going for it
yeah hold on
um
let's add ren where are you at rin
get the reaper up in here
funky freaking joke
cranky kang dude
um
came from
when i was at rocket jump we would just
come up with silly names off the top of
our head and we just take turns like all
day coming with stupid names and bonky
jojo was one of them
it's a really fun game you just come up
with stupid names like
crud marks mcgee
red marks
um
let's see
we got the chat popping off
call went to my pc
how about we try again
let's try it let's try the man himself
once more
let's just start he said okay
oh
he's joining
here we can add him we can add his voice
yes ren
hey he's in
yeah
yeah let me um
let me add discord real quick
as a
window capture
or audio source
audio
output
then you're gonna hear peter you're
gonna hear peter double
oh thank you
did i mute myself on discord
then how am i gonna hear peter oh i see
what you're saying i see you're saying
photo okay bear with us we're gonna get
red in here
um
oh no that's not what i want
maybe i'll just do a window capture no
hmm
that might be the easiest way yeah let's
do the ninja route
but let's get a game in first let's get
a gaming
yeah let's get a game in here
all right um
oh no i can't wait
that's who i wanted anyway
should i cancel it no no we're good
piranha plant
please
wait so can everybody here run right now
or no no no it's just me and you
but we can hear ren
ren don't say that you can't say that
by the way i have input lag so just to
let you know
all good
oh crunched out
flaps
um so let me know how the refresh rate
is and everything on the
on the playback for the stream
come here boy
all right cool
snapped here let me clap you real quick
you know jan
plays prana plant
really
get him
oh
sit
here boy
no dude
don't touch me with that tree
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh oh the elevator is cheap
you ran you think you're so good
so does the audio sound okay can you
hear like smash versus our voices are
all right
oh no
okay
okay cool
dude someone needs to like take care of
this plant
there we go
i can i can work the volume mixing after
this
i'm perfect
oh ren thinks he's good ron thinks he's
good
dude what is a stage hazard nonsense
oh my goodness
uh
leave me be leave me be
come here
snap
no
yeah i'm on those joy-cons too
oh no oh wow that was so lucky
oh no get off your high horse
oh my god oh my god
that was great
do that
uh
i don't know
that's what's up that's what's up
wren can't win on the stream ren can
never win on this stream ever again
oh
look at that seashell
try getting good okay here let me switch
my character
let me switch
pull out old trusty
it's ness
let's go pew
all right
bringing out old trusty
most annoying character
oh yeah
was good's toy chest man that's
that's an old time classic
wes is much better than me at twitch us
i'll admit it people are like what's toy
chest
bowser jr
it's over for both of you
that's right because you're scared
yo
oh no
oh that's a little hard to recover here
with the lag
just a little bit of input laggle
oh god damn it
dude he got hit
not me
that dark wind out of here
my wheelchair
i'm nothing without my wheelchair
oh ren okay
dude i'm i'm getting destroyed
dude stop stop bullying me
get them get them
oh
uh
no
yeah go on and get
uh
no
dude your stupid toys
i'm done playing with your toys dude
your toys
your toy chest
is dumb
no
oh god
oh ren this is what i've been waiting
for
[Music]
i don't know his moveset
eat it get out eat it
damn dude that's the same way you killed
me on
in that video that you did
the same exact place the same exact map
vicious just different character
i'm getting my real controller i'll be
back oh boy
i believe i won the last one
ah it's dead
it's okay
oh huh
it's weird because i'm getting levels
no game audio automatic background noise
canceling
how's that even possible though
hold on
oh yeah
how's that possible
like i'm getting the levels here
um
oh that's why
that's why i had it set to
uh
monitor only
[Applause]
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
are you ready
all right let's go
three
two
we got you a different level
huh
nice
nice
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
another
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god
oh
perfect what was it
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
nice
no
[Applause]
[Applause]
how do you fare against dean
with with uh
piranha
are you serious
[Applause]
that's the best
[Applause]
like that ball is just out there
[Applause]
i can't tell
this level's so big
yo go for a random battlefield next time
i gotta be careful about that
oh
[Applause]
are you healing yourself
what is that
[Music]
[Laughter]
same
same
same
no it didn't work i'm still on these
little controllers i'm playing like this
dude i'm playing like this you know just
one single little controller
nah i got the i got the dual jewelry
count
for everyone joining we're we're in
after hours right now we've uh we've
done the texturing
maybe this is confusing maybe i just
need to set up a second stream or
rename the video
wait i didn't change the thing
back out
output the discord let's try
audio output
uh
it's cool i'll we'll do it next time
[Applause]
do it
the dick [ __ ]
three
two one
go
[Music]
oh dude
that's brutal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
get in
grasp
oh rent this
you got the brunt that was so lucky
[Music]
how many stalks do i have i can't see
oh i know you have to
do i what no
these [ __ ] joycons dudes
man that's how many how many did i win
in a row i can't even i don't even know
uh
yeah last one for me
ggs
[Applause]
i want to change it up are you guys
going to change characters
yeah
going back to the classic
i'll keep it i'll keep it as is
any uh specific stages you guys are
feeling
this random battlefield
keeps us close
i need to figure out a way to play
or to like
i need to figure out a way where i'm not
playing through obs because there's that
lag
[Applause]
all right final match
wow
why did i jump right into that
uh
[Applause]
that's so scary
there's a poisonous fog
come on playing another tree
[Applause]
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
no what am i doing
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no
that was so bad
[Applause]
do it again peter do it again
i got this plant [ __ ]
[Applause]
stupid spike balls
where they even come from
[Applause]
lag town
[Applause]
no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh dude
that attack is so brutal
[Applause]
[Applause]
we can't find it
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
that was great
[Applause]
wasn't my day
[Applause]
yes i know
we textured earlier
this is after hours
picturing is finished
this game
[Applause]
yeah yeah man yeah thanks for joining us
ren
yeah we'll get your voice going next
time but uh have a good day have a solid
day yeah peace out
yeah later man all right it's been a
pleasure peter good times
yeah thanks for having me buddy
absolutely man enjoy yourself everyone
else thank you i'm gonna go get some
lunch yeah man go for it go for it i'll
talk to you soon alrighty
everyone else thank you
see y'all
bye bye thank you for stopping by
everybody good times everyone
uh i think i'll see you next week pretty
sure i'll see you next week
i'll be working on some unreal stuff so
until then
peace
[Music]
tip
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you